Speaker 1: This is a story that there was not a
lot of coverage of, but it is very disturbing. An
anti-vaccine, anti-gay street preacher has
reportedly killed his own wife because God
told him to. This is a wacky, wacky story. An
anti-vaccine street preacher has been arrested
for allegedly killing his own wife and allegedly
admitting it. So there's not too much doubt here,
but we're still being legally careful. The victim
is a 25 year old Kansas woman named Regan Marek.
She previously played goalie for the Kansas
University women's soccer team. At the time,
her name was Regan Gibbs on the team roster. Her
husband is 26 year old Chad Marek, suggesting
Marek is her married last name. According
to police, Chad Marek called 911 on himself
after this incident. The wife was dead when
emergency crews arrived. Tragic and disturbing
story. The suspect was one of these street
preachers who get a bullhorn and they do religious
stuff in populated areas and talk about Jesus.
He would also post videos online, which I'm not
going to be playing today. And in those videos,
he would attack COVID vaccines as spreading the
spirit of the Antichrist. He would warn people
that they are coming from your children. Who
is the very well? He would also warned that
the LGBTQ agenda is coming for your children.
So seemingly, that's what he means. He allegedly
told police. God told him to kill his wife.
Quote from Fox Four's Sheree Honeycutt. He
called police and said he has killed his wife.
Did he possibly say why he may have done
that? And a police representative said, quote,
He told us that God told him to do it. So this
is one of those cases where, you know, when we
talk about the the Buffalo shooter from now close
to roughly two weeks ago, a week and a half ago,
the right very quickly jumped to this is just
a mentally ill person, completely disconnected
from politics in all ways. Just does nothing
political here. Doesn't pass the sniff test. We
look at the manifesto from the Buffalo shooter and
we see that it's cogent fascism. It is very much
a seemingly coherently parodying and mirroring
the substance of the great replacement theory,
etc. stuff that we've seen parroted by people like
Tucker Carlson on Fox News and others. And yes,
to some degree, we can also say, well, most
mentally ill people never commit violence
and lots of people believe things that are
wrong. There's an additional element here
which certainly could be a factor. Nobody's
denying that. But we can't ignore the very real
kind of political basis for the crime, at least
in terms of the beliefs in this case. This was
an anti-vaxx pastor preacher. I guess preacher
is the right word, an anti-gay preacher, etc.
But it seems very secondary to this particular
crime. God told me to kill my own wife. This case
to create a. Contrast is the point. It seems
way more plausible to say the main thing here
was some form of mental illness. Now, of course,
it's we're diagnosing from a distance or not
really not really diagnosing, but we're evaluating
and speculating from a distance. In both cases,
we would need to know more and have more
firsthand knowledge. But the point here is to say,
when we cover up an incident by saying it's
only mental illness, we often intuitively say
it doesn't really make sense here. These are
the perfect contrasts when we say, well, mental
illness for the Buffalo shooter, very specific,
politically charged and cogent manifesto.
Mental illness there has a very obviously
different meaning then in this particular case
where a guy allegedly killed his wife because
God told him to. Not saying that there aren't
multiple factors to all of these stories, but
it should at least allow us to see how different
the meaning of mental illness can or might be in
different stories. Let me know if you agree with
the distinction I'm drawing here in what are
admittedly tragic events and very complicated
events to understand. Let me know your thoughts.
We'll take a quick break and be right back